kept everybody engaged that's important
co-op block by Allen this fleurs block
of the game out to Josh brave talk about
power give it to us
the Moussa miss it's Greek through the
nice ball fake and used all of the iron
to get it to go
and the Wolves now in transition with a
chance to pour the lead Martin call the
circus and Martin a little bit up
through right here behind the back watch
the step through and then the body on
body that's a guy that knows how to get
buckets right there really impressive
until Russell might not be the most
dynamic or athletic point guard but he
still feels like in spite as the
improvements he's already made that
there's still a lot more improvement to
be done for DeAngelo ruff say young man
he's got plenty of time to meet a nice
young lady let him do his thing he's a
rich young man exactly not to let it let
them just build the new bathroom for you
and leave him alone
dealt with that stuff about you know
Florida governor's versus
right and I get it I get it but you know
what very few of these weeks where the
great players have the same for each
game they advanced $5,000 so a little
bit of though the accumulation of cash
is that per team are preparing you know
how to log in
you don't had a long career in France
who's that Kenny Atkinson Allen he's got
a Nepal go stick unfair out of the
Crites unfair putting up the game and
bringing the mid-range to and the post
comes out then very on the drive tough
sledding inside rebound putback good by
the Timberwolves who continue to
dominate here hanukkah shots
game-winning shots in basketball
throughout history one of the most
iconic Michael Jordan's against Brian
Russell Oh foul line cool and clean a
Cleveland yeah
Tyler's been very good but he's been
consistent ever since the summer started
read inside with the slam great dime
from mcLaughlin fans chanting someone's
day yes I mean meet a prime again it
done
they've eaten meals together and they
noticed kids fighting for a career
that's cool Martin with the floater got
it and this sort of holding off the
Brooklyn and I are gonna be pumped for
that yeah you and I are gonna be ready
for an NBA Summer League championships
and once again friend we will not have a
repeat some early chance your was the
Portland Trailblazers
led by CJ McDaniel the championship game
MVP this year we will crown a nice
the final score 85-77 what's up you guys
this Taylor Brooks with bleacher report
make sure that you subscribe for some
more video content